in the United States you are you are
making the argument that we should not
criminally prosecute Obama because the
extrajudicial assassination of an
American citizen in a country we're not
at war with is Justified because that
was the son of someone we were targeting
in a different country
I I think if you start Prosecuting
presidents for war crimes after every
every president would go to prison and
then yes and they wouldn't be able to do
their job it's like telling a cop they
can't get rough with their with the guy
they're arresting it's at some point
we've got to let the president dupe war
no no I mean it's not commander-in-chief
of the military what do you you just
want to end just let other people win
the war I mean what do you so I don't
know what Abdul Rahman Allah was doing
that was helping these terrorists win
any kind of War other than drinking
coffee and having to have been related
to a guy no man they sent a message to
the dad right yes that's right so yeah
it's called the war crime